Just the last and final chapter of the subject and I think it's again,
we're starting,
uh,
by backing off a little bit towards the end of last class.
I think that may be parts of it with you or maybe difficult for you to follow
there.
Let me remind you what we were trying to do.
We had learned that space time,
it described before coordinates so that if you're following some particular,
some event,
you label it with four numbers,
CT,
x,
Y and Z,
which I want you to let me come by into the single vector are and they are
written as x zero x one x two x three.
Now I'm on two minds about x two and x three sometimes like carry them around.
Sometimes I don't.
X one is just normal family or x,
y [inaudible] it possible to arrange all the motion to take place in the x
direction,
in which case Y and Z don't change when you go from one frame to the other.
So I don't usually bother with that but sometimes I put it back because if you
had only two components x nor the next one you might say,
hey,
the world is two dimensional is I want to keep reminding you.
Now we think of it in terms of four dimensions,
so at least for that reason sometimes a carry all the three components that
position sometimes only one,
but I'm sure you guys can figure it out from the context which is which.
So going back to the simplest situation of only x and time,
the point of those coordinators is that if you went to a moving frame x one
prime will be x one minus Beta is zero divided by the square root and x zero
prime will be x zero minus Beta times x one divided by the square root where
Beta is to be oversea.
Sometimes it's useful to introduce gamma,
which is one minus a use squared overseas where also to prevent all confusion,
you will be the velocity of your frame relative to mine.
The will stand for the velocity of some particle that we are bought study.
So let's reserve the symbol before motion of actual particles,
which is why we are there.
We are all observers,
but we were observing something that's something has a velocity that I call
[inaudible] and you will call w and u is the speed relative to your frame and my
friend.
All right,
so this is the notion of space time because space and time are getting mixed up
when they go to a new frame of reference,
but even in this world,
but nothing is sacred.
The fallen combination is very important,
which we do notice X.
Dot.X is a new dark product.
Now in space time,
the new drug product will be the square of the time,
like part my minus the square of the space,
like part.
If you wanted to bring in all the components of space time,
then you can modify it to x square minus R.
Dot.
R R.
R will be x squared.
Plus y squared was the square.
So you can use either than rotation whenever possible.
I just keep to,
but you've got to remember this is why it's a four dimensional dot product and
this is the same for all people so I can calculate it.
You can calculate it are Exxon arts and x one will differ,
but it's the property of the learning strand summation that if I squared this
guy and subtract it from the square of this guy on the right hand side,
it's a magical things will happen and I'll get the same combination without the
primes.
That's like the length of the vector and that's called the spacetime interval.
Let's call that a square.
This face time interval,
if it took two events separated in space by Delta x and separated in time by
Delta t,
then we like to use the symbol delta and square for the space that I'm in
trouble.
That's the same thing applied to the differences rather than with the coordinate
themselves and this is invariant in gradient descent.
A term mathematicians use for saying same for all people are unaffected by
learns transformation.
It's the analog of how far you are from the origin.
In the old days when I took two frames,
one which is the standard x,
y or that is rotated x,
y.
If you go to the rotated frame,
the components x and y change,
but how far you are from the origin or what's the length of the vector is the
same for all people.
More generally the dot product of two vectors is in variant on the rotations and
this is the new dark product.
We use the symbol dark product,
but I don't draw arrows because if I don't draw any adverse and use capital
letters,
it means it's a four vector.
That's the expectation.
Then I said,
let's try to reason by analogy and try to invent a momentum vector.
How did we invent the momentum vector?
In the old days we said let the particle move a distance.
Delta are backlit,
Delta are in a time Delta t and a divide by Delta t and take some limit but I
know this is a vector because delta art is a difference in two vectors that the
particles now and various later difference of two vectors is also a tiny vector
going from here to there dividing by a scaler.
By scale I mean something that is not affected by rotations means taking it back
to that and multiplying it by some number.
Therefore there's also backtrack.
So this ratio is also a vector and the limit of this ratio is also a vector.
I'm sorry I forgot the mass here and we call it the moment the matter
so you can manufacture vectors starting with the position vector by taking
derivatives with respect to something like that is the same for all observers
were observers.
I meant in the old days people with an ax is rotated any way you like.
I wanted the same thing now in this present problem,
but I would not want to define obviously afford dimensional vector,
so do the four dimensional vector.
My plan is to define something called momentum,
which is now going to be the tank in this fort position divided by something.
Question is what do I divided by?
I cannot divide by Delta.
T in the old days dumped that he was a sacred number.
Same for all people.
No Delta t is like Delta x and Delta whites and one of the components and you
don't defy divide the change in the vector components by the change in one of
the components to get a velocity.
You gotta divide by something that's going to play the role of time and have the
same value for all people.
Well we sort of know what the quantity is.
Obviously if a particular is moving from here to here in space time,
this is x not equal to CT and this is x one.
It moves to distance delta x one in a time built and t
and we know that for this piece of its motion,
the following quantity,
Delta s with the C Delta t squared minus Delta x squared is the same for all
people.
Yeah,
so I should really be dividing by this.
Let me write it slightly differently.
I see Delta t square root of one minus delta x over Delta,
t square one oversee square.
So we had asked her divide by this crazy thing.
Well let me write this crazy thing a c times something I want to call ditto.
Ditto is the tea time is square root of one minus Delta,
x over Delta t squared times one overseas square.
Then I said we can give a meaning to this thing.
In fact,
let's,
let's take,
did I ever do with the specter of Tau,
not s they differ only by this factor c which is a constant so it doesn't matter
how has the interest of time and you can ask what does that time stand for?
It's not the time according to me,
but I argue that it's the time according to the potluck.
Why?
Because you can evaluate this quantity in any frame you like.
So go to the frame moving with the Party and moving with the particle and if
you're here now and that later,
later,
the certainly later,
but he had remains here for the party.
It doesn't move in his own frame,
so delta x will vanish.
Therefore,
Delta s simply reduces to see that pimy me or according to the party.
So ditto is the time elapsed according to the particular itself.
Okay?
According to party,
that's what we're going to divide by.
So it's a very clever way to circumvent the question of what's really take the
derivative with respect to my time in your time.
All our variable,
we don't agree on it,
but let's ask how much time elapsed according to the one thing we are studying.
Let's divide by that time.
That answered will be the same because you and I may not agree on how long it
took to go from here to there,
but we can all ask how long did the particle say took to go from here to there.
We're talking about the same thing and we'll get the same answer.
Okay?
You'll get the particle time.
You got to take the time according to you and me and multiply by this factor.
This factor,
by the way,
is nothing but the usual time dilatation.
Okay?
Because of the politics of series,
it took time.
Ditto because the clock is slower.
Exactly.
This amount.
I will say it took longer by this summer.
Yeah,
so let's rewrite this in a way that's going to be more than helpful to us.
Take the ratio and write DT over detail is one over square root of one minus B
squared.
C squared.
I'm going to use that in a minute.
That just says the time according to me and the time according to the particle
are related by the time dilatation factor that's controlled by the velocity of
the particle.
Now we had ready to define the forward momentum p four moment than fee is going
to be m times DX,
not the Tao names.
Em.
Uh,
the x one detail.
I'm not going to bother with the other components.
You can always put them back.
But x snottier remember was Ct.
So this really becomes m d t divided by detail.
James M,
the x divided by detail.
Okay.
This is guaranteed to be a four vector.
That means if you know the components of this in one frame of reference and he
called one of them as p zero and you call this one p one then in a moving in a
frame that's moving relative to what speed you,
a p zero prime will be p zero minus Beta Times p one over the square root and p
one prime will be p one minus Beta times visit over the square root.
It'll transform just like the components of X.
Yes.
Where did the sea,
uh,
no,
I did not go.
You're quite right.
I see a [inaudible] CT quite right.
It is c times VP.
You need that then this is correct.
So we got afforded vector,
but we don't know what it means because we don't know what detail means.
It's of course it's the time according to the article,
but I don't care about politics.
I'm studying this particle.
I got my own clock.
I got me on meter sticks.
I want to think in terms of time according to me,
period.
Well,
we can do that.
They can do that by going to anything.
When you take an event like this,
the x one d Tao and you can write it as Dx One d tee times DTD toe,
the x one d t something.
We understand it's just the velocity according to you and me.
If you use that rule here,
you will find the momentum has got components m times c,
d t d tau is Dt tee,
which is one times d divided by the Tao,
which is this factor here.
And the second thing will be m v divided by the same.
In other words you can take,
you can trade out of it is for t derivatives everywhere provided you attach this
factor.
That's the ratio of the Tao database through the tweet.
They did have it.
So now I have afforded vector.
I still don't know what it means,
but at least it is written in terms of things with are baric operations
significance for me,
I see a particular movie,
it's got a velocity.
Put that in and I get this thing.
Apparently the relativity theory says this should play the role of momentum but
afford dimensional momentum in your new world.
If you wanted to bring the other components,
we will put an arrow.
We can keep it or leave.
It doesn't matter.
No.
Notice once again that,
okay,
I'll continue some more.
I have already done this last time,
but let me remind you,
we looked at this guy and said,
look at small velocities,
Ben,
be overseas,
but it's small.
The denominators just one numerators and B.
Then I said,
Aha,
that's the momentum,
so it must be that with all these factors,
this is the momentum in the new relativistic theory.
The new [inaudible] momentum is not just mass times velocity,
mass times velocity divided by all this stuff.
The theory says,
use that as your momentum.
That's good.
Then be a say,
okay,
that's my momentum.
Who is this?
I expanded this out for small velocity.
If you put velocity equals zero,
you get mc that looks like this,
the mass,
and we don't know what that corresponds to in your just the mass.
Nothing kinematic will.
But if you expand the square root a little further out to one more term,
be found that the zero component p Zero looks like mc times one plus B squared
over two C's were less.
Dot,
dot,
dot.
That'd become mc plus one half MV squared times one oversea lists dot,
dot,
dot.
And now I finally have something I understand because one half MV squared is
familiar at Kennedy energy,
but I don't like this annoying.
See here,
if I multiply both sides by sea,
I learned that c times p zero
is MC square.
Bless one half Mv Square.
That's more stuff.
That's more and more powers that we oversee.
But this,
I argue since that's the kinetic energy,
everything is an energy formula to the whole thing stands for energy.
So I learned that the first component of p is energy divided by c.
So I come back here and I write business energy divided by c.
So put all,
if you are,
for many of you who found some of this mathematics,
uh,
difficult to follow.
It depends.
For me it was love at first sight is,
this is really when I said I want to go into the business.
For some reason this would work for me,
but it doesn't matter what you have to know is what I'm going to tell you now.
Operationally,
I'm not going to hold you responsible for this part of the material at all.
For me,
it's part of explaining how logically starting with the very first axiom first
to ask him if you can did use everything,
but now I'll tell you operationally what you guys are supposed to know.
You are supposed to learn the following two things.
In the old days we at time and Viet space,
there've been United in a single quantity CT are which be right.
This two zero x one it's it other words,
the three components of a vector joined with one quantity that looked like a
scaler together to form a four dimensional object.
Nobel learning that that is another four dimensional object.
One of it is just the momentum and the other does energy divided by C.
I'd be wanting to call that as p Zero p one
again,
the familiar momentum,
which is a vector join with another quantity,
which is the best way to think about it as candidate energy plus rests energy
plus other corrections,
but it's the scalar.
It doesn't depend on orientation of access in the old days,
but now under load and transformation,
namely when you go from one frame to another,
e and p will all mixed with each other,
just like x and t will mixed with these other.
But this is the new form factor.
This call the energy momentum for vector.
Just like that's called the space time for vector.
That's the energy moment in Florida vectors.
So all over the lid tivity you will find three objects visit to be part of a
vector will combine with the fourth one,
which used to be a scalar.
Together they will form a new four dimensional vectors.
So we should know the following.
When we are studying particle dynamics,
we have to know,
uh,
in more detail.
I'll,
in fact,
let me dedicate the whole board to that is very important.
You know,
definition is that it's he oversee and P.
Yup.
Well it looks like mc squared plus one half MV squared plus other stuff.
Right?
So I recognize one half MV squared as an energy.
Then the other powers in volume,
we're at the fourth stage,
the fourth,
they're all corrections obviously to the energy at higher velocity.
This like momentum.
Even in the literalistic,
teddy was not MV started out like MV,
but when you expand the denominators and power,
so we oversee,
we'll get more and more corrections.
I identify this as an energy because if I go to very low velocities it reduces
to the rest mass with doesn't ever go into change plus a one half MV squared,
which played the role of kinetic energy.
Right?
That's the way it has units of energy and one term and it looks like energy.
So the whole thing,
the theory is telling you is all just the energy of the party.
In the old days in velocity is a very small,
we saw only the two terms of written one half MV squared and Mc Square Mc Square
we hadn't bothered with because it doesn't change in any coalition you add the
MC squared is before each particle has got its own Mc square before and after.
They simply cancelled is the one half MV squares before and after that would
equal and we use that to solve collisions.
Now we will be told you should use the conservation of this energy and the
conservation of this momentum in a coalition.
Okay,
so the first thing is this is e and this is p.
Anyone says what is e MC squared divided by one minus B squared.
Receipt Square and P in one dimension is MBA divided by one minus B squared over
c squared.
This you must know,
so momentum,
middle 30 looks a bit like the old momentum but it's got this ubic with this
factor and energy looks really weird.
It doesn't look like anything on earth.
But if we expand this and power Sylvie,
you will see the term terms we rode down rest,
energy plus everything else you can call energy of motion.
And the first chairman of the energy of motion is the familiar one half Mv
Square.
In other words,
this is how the world always was.
It was revealed to us in the old days when we only looked at low energy
particles as MC squared plus one half MV squared.
And we can see the dot.dot terms because we oversee,
we're so small,
the fourth power and six power and eight part of you oversee or too small for us
to detect.
Likewise,
the of a particle
was never MV.
It is MV divided by all this.
But for small valleys,
we oversee look like that and we figured,
hey,
that's what is really happening.
So we were looking at an approximation.
But these quantities in the old days when velocities are small and as velocities
go up,
uh,
those quantities that are useful,
this is what the theory says should play the role of the new Ford momentum.
So the significance of this being afforded momentum.
First of all is what is written on the top right corner there.
Namely,
if you know the energy and momentum in one frame,
you can find the energy and momentum in another frame of reference.
Moving relative to me for that purpose,
you should take the energy and divide by C,
we should call it p not the momentum can be left as it is and this will behave
like x,
not that'll be him like x one under Lorentz transformation.
Yeah.
Well there are other consequences of the fact that P is afforded vector first
consequences.
This,
you'd remember the dot product of a vector with itself.
It's the same for all observers.
So what's the dot product?
The p with the,
with itself?
Well let,
before I do that,
let me remind you in general into the activity.
You will have four vectors,
eh,
they'll have a one part that looks like time and one part that looks like an
ordinary vector
and B,
it's another four vector.
It's got a part that looks like time.
And another part that looks like an ordinary lecture.
It's a union of a former vector with the farmer scaler.
And they will transform it.
A load than Samsung nation,
just like x and,
and t.
But the fallen quantity a Darby,
we can say zero be zero minus usual.
Dot.
Product of the spacial components is in video.
That means all people will agree on this quantity
and a special cases,
eight dot.
A.
Dot.
A is equal to 80 zero square minus the length of the vector park,
which for our purpose will be just a zero squared minus 81 square.
This is all reasoning by analogy.
Yep.
No,
all right,
Lisa.
Quarterly answers slightly different objects.
Uh,
you can form with his phone number numbers something that you've made color
[inaudible] right.
Uh,
they would invent it before it was distributed by Hamilton and they have a great
mathematical beauty and they generalization of numbers.
Uh,
you know,
we generalize real numbers to complex numbers.
Then you went from complex numbers and things called quaternions.
They are also numbers.
You can multiply them by each other,
but the product a B differs from the product B.
So it's a demo.
They had call a hyper complex numbers where the audit in which you multiply them
matters.
Okay,
so now let's take,
let's ask,
what is the invariant length square of the momentum for vector with itself?
That means you got to do p Zero Square minus p square.
Yeah,
that means you're trying to take m zero.
I'm sorry,
you're going to take mc over this factors square minus M v over this factor
squared.
But let's try to do this in our head guys.
M squared is going to come out to the whole thing.
You agree the top I have got one over one minus B squared.
Oversee Square,
you have to have minus V squared over one minus B squared overseas square.
So they have a lot of cancel giving you MC squared,
uh,
m squared,
c squared.
So the fallback that of any particle has a length that does not at all depend on
how fast it's moving.
The depends only on this,
when you talk take a velocity vector for a particle,
it doesn't have a fixed length party.
They can be moving slow.
It can be moving fast.
So be x,
quiet plus v Y squared could be whatever you like depending on how it's moving.
But this relativistic length square of afforded vector is independent of
velocity because the velocity here,
when combined with this,
I'm just cancel so well that's just the way it is.
Now,
if you're not good in Algebra,
that's a shortcut for finding this.
Let me tell you what the shortcut is and we love the shotguns because they very
helpful and the model of the study is also illustrated by the shotgun.
I wanted to find p.
Dot.
P it's an invariant because it's like a dark product so anybody can calculate
it.
How about somebody writing with the particle?
If you're writing with the particle,
your zero component is m zero C is MC.
There's no velocity for you and you have no momentum as the particle.
There's no momentum as seen by the particle.
So the components of the vector p become MC and zero.
What's the length square?
This vector,
but it's a square of this guy and case closed.
There's nothing here to subtract from here.
That's a quick way to verify that this,
like the vector with itself is in fact m squared,
c squared.
In other words,
the trick is right with the particle and calculate the vector and the vector is
only one component.
Namely Mc doesn't have a spatial part because it's not moving according to
itself.
That's what p.
Dot.
P's m squared,
c squared.
So people write it also as follows.
Uh,
remember p zero was he oversee.
This is p square,
m square,
c square.
I don't rate it.
This is one way the write it explicitly,
but here is how people write it.
Multiply both sides by square and right east square physical disease where p
square,
let's m squared c to the fourth.
Uh,
that deserves a box.
That's how we remembered it.
I have just rearrange this equation.
P.
Dot.
P is m squared,
c squared by definition.
P.
Dot.
P is the timeline component.
Square minus spatial components where we agree the time like part is you oversee
especial part is just the momentum.
So I've just rearranged it to get this
and it says the energy of the particle depends on his momentum.
If it comes completely the rest,
you kill this term that's equal MC squared.
That's the rest energy of a product.
No,
I am almost finished with the kinematics except for one thing that are strange
particles in the world called photons.
Photon has no rest mass.
Therefore if you namely went by any of these formulas,
if you kill the massive before time,
you might think energy and momentum vanish because m is going to zero,
but we all know enough mathematics and know that if the zero on the top you
could beat it.
If there's a zero in the bottle,
that blocker only for be equal to c.
So politic is moving at the speed of light.
Do have energy and momentum,
but they don't come from a mass divided by something or mass times velocity,
but be something they simply have energy and momentum that obeys this equation
without an m on the right hand side for the fourth time he square equal to c
times.
P Square is what?
A four time obs.
So four times can have energy.
Photons can have momentum,
but the energy would be c times that woman.
So that if you find the invariant squared at the fort on momentum,
you will get zero.
So fortnights or particles who's momentum squared is zero,
where the square is the four dimensional square with the times squared minus the
spacial square.
So let me summarize,
um,
once more for people who may not want to follow every detail,
the practical part of what you must understand from what I've been teaching,
you said when you study a single material particles which has a mass so that it
can be brought to rest and made to sit on the table,
we associate with that afforded vector.
The first part of that is the energy oversee.
The second part of that is called the momentum and the explicit formula for
these are m zero or MC divided by this and end the embedded by this.
And one can explicitly verify that p.
Dot.
P is m squared,
c squared.
This is it.
This is somebody of all that I've said.
You don't know anything at all.
Notice
yes.
When you're ready,
eat up that either on the right.
Yeah.
A Capitol p without any address on it.
I supposed to be afforded vector and the dot.
Product of it is defined as the square of the first component minus the way.
The second one
that's correct
and four,
four times.
We always like to use the symbol k by the momentum of a photon rather than p.
Luckily people like read more or less back convention fought on momentum is
called k and more sometimes and I just called Q by some people,
but we will call it k.
Yeah,
and the energy of the photon is going to be called Omega momentum before time is
going to be called k
and the condition is we'll may go equal to KC and that's the condition k.
Dot.
K equals zero.
Yeah,
k squared if you like shorthand for k.
Dot.
K Zero four four times four times a particle is square to the four.
Momentum is zero material particles that can come to rest have a square at the
Ford momentum which is m squared,
c squared.
This is really,
this is something you have to know.
Another thing you have know is that when I write them in this notation as four
vectors,
you should know the following.
You found all the components,
p zero and p one in one frame
and you move the electrode to me or speed you p zero prime and p one prime with
related to p zero and p one by the Lord and his transformation.
Yes,
like zero prime and x one prime are related to x one and x by that formula on
the top left.
Last thing I wanted it to,
I'm going to do a lot of problems for you so you get used to doing the
relativistic kinematics.
Last thing I wanted to tell you is why do we take this definition on momentum?
Okay,
you agree that theory naturally gave out something that it said deserves to be
called momentum,
but why do we Watson Nice about this?
Why is it important that the momentum and energy form of vector,
I'm going to give you a reason for it and try to follow the reason,
the whole advantage of energy and momentum.
What is the big deal about energy and momentum?
Let me ask you that.
Yes you have concern they have or not useful unless the specialist utility came
from the fact they are concerned.
So you can put a restriction on possible coalitions you add the moment than
before.
It's got agree with momentum after you add the energy before it's got.
I agree with the energy after of course in the Nativity,
energy and momentum had been assembled into four vector.
So conservation of momentum will mean really for equations.
The zero part will be the energy before we put the energy after and the three
special parts will be x component.
The moment before it will be x component after them.
So on.
That's all very good.
But you got to make sure that if a momentum is conserved for me for momentum,
it must also be conserved for you.
There's no use having a quantity that's concerned for me and not concerned for
you.
So by the time you bring up something and say they're going to use it as a
concern quantity,
you've got to make sure the conservation law is not limited to one observer.
And that's what I want to show you.
I won't argue without writing any equations that if energy and momentum are
concerned for me,
they are going to be conserved for you because they are vectors.
Let's understand why.
Suppose you got a coalition.
A lot of particles come in.
One particle brings momentum energy p one other one brings out energy and
momentum p two and at the end of the coalition maybe they become party country
and particle foreign particle five in Duluth,
dualistic theories.
If two particles come in,
you can have 36 particles coming out.
In fact,
that's why they build accelerators.
If two went in and two came out,
it's a waste of time.
You can smash into things and would that energy you can produce matter.
So it's not a mistake I've made.
I do mean that sometimes too can go into three or four five.
Let's take an example where this is true.
Each p is a four component object like this.
Suppose I say incoming equals outgoing
love.
You see the whole coalition from your frame of reference.
Then I maintain that the numbers you get,
the one frame and P to prime will also equal B prime plus before Brian,
let's be five prime that's guaranteed and I want to tell you why.
Suppose this for ordinary vectors,
let me make life simple by saying at p one plus p two became p three
okay?
What that means is one vector p one another vector p two added up to one vector
p three exit visa,
not ordinary arrows.
They said ad works in four dimensions.
The fact that two arrows add up to a third one are equal do third one means the
former triangle.
Now they can form a triangle for me and you can stand on your head and do what
you like.
It'll still be true even though it looks like this,
it is still true that this guy,
this guy is equal to that guy.
You have two vectors add up to third one.
Namely if a summer two vectors is equaled another vector,
namely the lefthand side vector,
it is equal right handset vector.
Going to rotate.
That frame will continue to say that the rotated vector is equally rotated back.
That's because equal vectors upon rotation will remain equal vectors.
That's the whole point.
The total incoming momentum for vector Khalid fee incoming,
and this is the outgoing momentum college,
the p outgoing.
If p incoming is equal to p outgoing for me,
so two vectors that equaled space time for the rotator observer there will be
equal.
Do you understand why?
Because it my total incoming vector will undergo Lord Samsung nation to become
your incoming vector.
My outgoing vector will go along and transformation to find your outgoing,
but if the input of the Lord in his transformation is the same,
the output will also be the same because you will be putting the very same
numbers to get out the output numbers.
That's why it's very important that this momentum that we have be used because
it does a chance that if it's concerned in one frame,
it's conserved in all frame.
If you went and said,
you know what,
I don't like your formulas.
I am really wedded to this formula for momentum.
What you'll find is that even if it's conserved in your frame of reference,
in a different frame of reference,
that combination,
some over envy will not be concerned.
Okay?
That's the final,
uh,
property of four directors you've got to use.
Again,
if you don't follow the details,
you must know that in coalitions that we are going to study,
we will add up all the four vectors coming in will equate them to all the four
vectors going.
That's it.
So now I'm going to do sample problems to get you a feeling for that.
So as usual,
they will start out with the simplest one and then try to make it more
complicated.
So the first problem is this.
I am standing here,
I got some mass m and therefore time is coming towards me with some moment than
p
and it just hits me on the face and I absorbed the photon.
It's completely possible for the atoms forming my body to absorb a photo.
They absorb it.
So in the end,
that is no four ton.
That is me.
But possibly with a new mass in prime
into the list of collisions.
That is nothing called inelastic collisions.
You remember in the old days the one thing came and start to another thing and
they move together.
Momentum is conserved,
but energy is not.
There is no such thing.
Energy will always be conserved in the linguistic theories.
In other words,
even though this is a big,
I'm a single unit,
you might say,
what happened to the energy previously?
I had a moving photon on,
I got nothing moving here.
Well first of all,
I will be moving.
Secondly,
I'll have more mass.
Best thing is to consider the two particles coming in opposite directions.
They collide and form a new mass in the activity that has no momentum in the
final particle is not moving at all.
But it'll be more massive than before.
And that extra mass times c squared will be the extra energy brought by the
party consent form it.
So anyway,
the question here is what does m prime,
that's what we have to figure it out.
So the equation we will use is,
I would call my momentum is p and I would call p one as the initial one and Pete
was the final one.
Let's write down all the equations we can.
The only equation in town is k plus p one equals p two
case.
Now,
everybody is afforded vectors,
so don't be fooled.
It's 40 questions,
but in this problem,
luckily since there is no motion perpendicular the x axis,
we can have this x moment.
There's no need for y and z because the photon comes this way.
It can knock me and I can start moving this way,
but all the action is in the aesthetics.
So he had it.
It'll be actually two dimensional vectors and not for that's nothing vertically
before or after,
it'll be zero equals zero.
So what are those equations?
Before they do that,
let's write down the momentum of the photon.
First
momentum of the photon has got some energy.
I may go,
we may go oversea and it got some momentum.
K,
we had Omega Equals Casey.
You got to remember that p one has got an energy which is mc and no special
moment and because I'm not moving
at the end of the day P two I am moving,
but I also have a new mass and I have a new velocity which we don't know
going to have m frame be.
It might've best way to the one minus B squared over c square.
No.
All of you should be able to write this part down.
If you're not,
you should take a minute to think about it.
You can stop me,
you can question me,
but if you cannot do this,
you cannot do any of the problems.
You've got to think,
would I have done this?
Does it make sense to me?
What's the book?
Bookkeeping is all in the top.
Then you got a material particle.
It's first term zero component will be m times c divided by the square root of
all those things,
but the particle is addressed.
You only have mc that is normal mental.
The final object me after they hit the got hit by the fourth time I'm recoiling
so I will have a velocity.
I don't know what it is,
but my energy in terms of that,
the first term,
the zero will be this.
This will be p one.
No,
the law of conservation of Energy and momentum,
namely k one plus B one equals k two plus B two will really be saying all the
energy parts are the zero components.
We'll add a before and after and the first component is the ladder before and
after.
In other words,
Omega Oversea Plus Mc,
would it be equal to m primacy over this,
then k plus zero will be equal and Prime v divided by this.
This is not any different from the old days we had law of conservation of
momentum.
You allow conservation of energy except energy is not one half MV squared.
Energy is this crazy thing.
Plus even if a particle is not moving,
don't forget to give it MCS the energy.
That's the new part.
So what does the,
what is the question I asked you?
I said,
what does m prime,
so your job is to take these two simultaneous equations,
just one and this one and on foot m prime.
So what should I do?
What do you,
can you think of a strategy that'll give me m prime?
Yes.
Okay.
Right side of that equation.
Yeah.
Into this one here.
Yep.
You still have to sign for m prime and you also don't know the velocity here.
Memory of sound for the velocity and the episode for the employer.
If you say,
what does the unknown's and what are the known,
so let's be very clear.
The photon is a known momentum and on energy that's given to you.
Initial me has a mass m that's given to you.
Your job is to find the unknown mass m prime and the unknown velocity.
Do questions for two or not,
but they are not simple linear equations where you can add and subtract.
Okay?
The simple linear equations are multiply this by three,
multiply that by four and subtract and you'll get what you want is more
complicated.
The trick that you really want to use is the fact that for any particle,
if it took the square up the zero component,
so platform with the square of the spatial component,
the answer will be in Prime Square,
c square.
So I'm seeing this square,
mine is,
this square will be in prime time,
see square.
And that you get by taking this square up,
this minus two squared up this,
you can juggle that,
but I'm not going to do it that way.
I'm going to show you much more efficient and rapid way to do this.
So let's do it the most efficient way.
So let me come down here.
So you can see
here,
it's the shortcut.
Shotgun is the work entirely with four vectors and report dimensional dot
products and don't get down to the ugly business or writing each component.
We know that p two is p one plus K,
right?
And who are we?
After we had after m prime,
then we remember that p two square,
namely p two.
Dot.
P two is equal to m prime square.
C Square.
Yes.
So the question you had asked this,
nobody asked you how fast I am moving after I got hit.
By the fourth time you only asked me what is my numerous mass.
So you have swallowed the photon.
So I way more.
It's really that.
How much more do a waste?
The question,
namely what is my rest mass?
Namely,
I swallowed it and I recoiled and if you've traveled with me and find me at
rest,
what mass end primarily measure.
So no one's asking me my velocity of Recoil v.
So you shouldn't bother to calculate that.
You could if you wanted to,
but no one asking you that.
So go directly for p two square.
The quantity we're looking for is m prime square.
See Square.
That's gotta be p one plus k,
the whole thing.
Square.
Well do the old Algebra.
That's equal to p one squared plus k square.
Let's twice p one.
Dot.
K.
Okay.
Now let's see if I can do
what we do next.
What do you like to guess?
Yes.
No.
Do you know any of these quantities?
Do we know anything about what I've offered?
Three terms of written here?
Yes.
K squared is zero because of what?
For the photon.
I told for any particle,
the squared up its momentum.
It's really the squatter for its mass time.
Cs where for photons I totally long back Kdot case,
you know?
Yeah.
You don't have to worry about that.
How about the square of the momentum of the of me?
Well,
that was my rest mass before
IMC squared plus zero.
Now P one.
Dot.
K.
You got to be careful that dark product means,
let me write down the director of p one and can put you p one was Mc and zero
and k was the Omega oversea and especial momentum at Omega was equal.
The Casey got,
remember that
put a photon.
Once you pick the energy,
you have no choice with a moment.
Magnitude of momentum has to be a magnitude of energy divided by c.
So let's take p.
Dot.
K,
let's try to do p one.
Dot.
K.
Remember.
Dot.
Product of two vectors is time.
Time is time.
M C times,
we may go oversea minus space.space.
That was you.
So I canceled that and I find this really,
and we'll make up
and that's equal to m prime c squared.
Yep.
Can you just remind me what the uh,
what the Omega stands for again?
Yeah,
the four time.
Remember the four directors.
First Component is energy oversea.
Second component is a momentum.
It's traditional to call the energy of the photon by the symbol omega and a
Spanish.
I'm to call the momentum moment the Maga round,
the usual momentum by the symbol k.
And that's pretty helpful.
Otherwise you can have p one and p two and p one sub zero and k one sub zero to
many indices.
So what we're trying to do is whenever we write a k was components at Omega and
little K,
we know we're talking about the photon and Ben [inaudible],
I know I'm talking about the electron.
So Omega is destined energy up the photon.
So now if I can sell all the c squares and they get and prime square and square
plus two m Omega overseas,
now you can take the square root if you like,
and that's the answer.
So my mass would have gone up.
You might think,
how much would the mass have gone up?
We will say,
well,
this guy swallowed a four ton of Energy Omega.
So maybe that energy overseas squint will be the change in mass.
That is not correct.
And you got to think about why that's not the answer.
Why is that wrong?
Wait,
listen,
the photon energy turned into my extra mass.
Yes,
I know.
In other words,
when I observed the Fortran,
I also have to require to consider the momentum of the photon.
Consequently,
my final energy will equal all energy plus four ton energy.
But that does not mean all.
If it does rest energy that doesn't manage your emotion.
So you got to make sure that in the end you calculators so that the total energy
is balance,
but it's not contained in restaurants because you produce the rest mass in.
You also moved the rest mass.
And for all of that,
you've got only the energy of the photon to work.
Yeah.
Okay,
so this is,
uh,
this is one problem.
I was going to do one or two more,
but I want to make sure you guys are falling.
I just don't know.
Uh,
see if I ask you what you would do next.
If you have some idea,
then we can proceed.
But if you don't know,
maybe we should slow down and you've got to talk about which part of it you find
more difficult.
So let me say a few things.
And the first time you hear something that you find difficult,
you've got to put your hand up.
Okay?
Otherwise you're not going to make progress.
First thing I say is this particles of mass having energy and momentum that
depend on their velocity and rest mass as given by the first equation
and the energy and momentum,
but assembled into a four vector.
The first component that we just,
he oversee second company.
There's just a momentum that much you should know.
Secondly,
if it took the dot product of that vector with itself for the dot product is
defined in to be Lawrence invariant.
So that the same for all people,
that's p zero squared minus p one square.
You will always get m squared,
c squared for any particular Massa independent of its state of motion.
And the simplest way to get,
remember that is to evaluate the dot product in the frame moving with the
particle in that frame,
it only has a p zero which is mc and doesn't have a spatial momentum.
So that's gotta be the answer.
Second thing when you deal with for Trans is a little tricky for tons of energy.
Photon some momentum,
but energy is not mass times velocity squared over two,
etc. They have no mass,
but they have energy in their momentum.
And the condition of the photon is that the energy must be momentum times.
See that'll make sure that k.
Dot.
K is,
you know,
because for a particular mass m we,
I showed you the relation,
he square equals c times p squared plus m squared,
c to the fourth.
But for town there is no app that means equal the PC.
So four times energy in photon momentum have related magnitude.
Yes.
Yeah.
That's what I'm telling you for for four it's not defined as MV over something.
It is not defined that way because you,
you don't even get off first base without because m vanishes and be equal to
zero you are in real trouble.
So you've got to realize that for Portland as an exception,
how do you think about,
you don't think of it as an object of some mass that moves and sm energy and
some momentum.
It always moves at one speed.
You might say if it always moves at one speed,
it must have only one unique moment.
That's not true either.
So they are a little tricky for for trans you have to accept the fact that for
Trans have energy and four times of momentum with equal a PC and apart from that
there is no restriction.
You can give a fort on any energy,
like as long as the momentum you give it,
it says that each squared equals c squared,
p squared,
and you cannot go to the frame in which the photon is at rest.
There is no such thing.
It has no rest mass particles with notice.
Mass can have energies and can have momentum.
You know my,
the son,
when the inner four times hit you,
you can feel the force that's called radiation pressure.
So they carry momentum,
they carry energy.
But the formula for momentum energy is not written in terms of a mass.
So that's the second thing I've said.
Yes.
Yeah,
for the photon.
Yeah.
Yes.
P Zero Equals R K zero equals k one for the time.
And if I wrote k zero is Omega oversee than it means Omega Equally Casey.
Yeah,
that's the second statement.
That's not obvious from anything I taught you.
So that's new subs,
new stuff.
Because suddenly I got an object with no mass and my whole derivation for
momentum started with an time,
some velocity and so on.
So that fails for four plans,
but they exist and they carry energy.
They carry momentum.
You should think of them as particles that obey e squared equals c squared plus
[inaudible] squared,
c to the fourth with m equals to zero,
so they will be equal species.
That's the second statement.
Third statement is in a collision you add up all the piece in the case for
everybody on the left and that that's equal sum of all the pieces in the case on
the right
and you do that,
so you got to make sure that you can do that part for particles.
I will tell you this particular,
this rest mass is going at this velocity.
Then it should be able to build up this energy and momentum
for photons.
I won't tell you it's,
this is the velocity.
Velocity is always see for four times,
I have to tell you,
this is the Omega of the Photon is the care of the photon.
So you farm a little vector with Omega oversee as the first component and cares
the second one.
Then it's very,
then it's very easy at all.
The first column,
Second Column,
Third Column,
fourth column,
and those four things are separately conserved.
That's it.
That's the trick.
The coalitions balancing energy and momentum in one mega equation,
which is for momentum before is for momentum after.
And the beauty is any observer can look at this coalition from any frame of
reference.
Different people will disagree on what's the energy and watch the momentum of
the particle.
For example,
in this example I gave you,
I said I am addressed and I got hit by a Fortran,
then I'm moving.
Well that's the point of view of some observer for whom I was at rest initially.
You can see the whole thing from a rocket.
In that case,
uh,
my initial momentum,
we'll have a special part because the rocket,
I'll be moving backwards.
This photon will also have a new omega and a new cables you can find from
learning transformation.
This final object,
we'd be moving at some speed,
so everything will look different.
Nonetheless,
the momentum and energy will balance on the two sides for you as well.
Yes.
Pardon me.
Ah,
no.
You gotta be very careful about what you mean by mass.
Some people think a master's m divided by square root of one minus B squared
over.
I never want to take the point of view the only masters,
the rest mass and nobody will disagree on what the rest mass of a particle is.
You understand that I may think the particulates at rest,
you may think it's moving that is fine,
but if he bought asked the following question,
what does mass in a frame in which the particulates addressed the answer to that
person as a unique answer to find that you go sit with the particle and definers
maths so the rest of mass in this case m and m prime are Sam for all people.
You could see the whole coalition,
the rocket,
the end prime missed.
The employer e and p are transforming as Lauren's variables but m is a length
square for four vector and therefore it's the same for all people
can have.
I want to do a second very interesting problem
which is this,
the year is 1950 something for got 53 or 54 you are trying to build a collided
and Berkeley
is going to have a proton target.
By the way,
I'm going to show you one more trick.
It's a very useful put c equal to one everywhere.
You can always put sequel one by choice of units.
For example,
if your unit of length instead of being a meter stick was three times 10 to the
eight meters and that was your new unit of length,
that's called a light second for you.
The velocity of light is one because it goes one light second in one second and
distance over time will be one even if that's not your unit.
I said forget about c,
do the math without see in the end you can always put back the sea will always
know in the end how to put back the sea.
Maybe you have an example here.
Yeah.
In this problem,
if I had forgotten,
see everywhere I'll get an answer that looks like this.
M prime squared as m squared plus 2:00 AM Omega.
I already know that.
If that's a mask where and that's a mass square,
well that's a mass and that's an energy.
So I know that should be a season where here you can always find the city square
or the end of the day.
There's no reason to carry it from the beginning.
Just from dimensional analysis.
When you're looking for an energy,
you see a mass port where there,
when you're looking for a mass and you see an energy and it should be a mass
divided by c square.
So that's what I'm going to do.
So here is a proton addressed.
Here is a proton that I've created from my bebber Tron,
which is going to come and smash into this.
And the job of this reaction is the following,
whether there's notations,
very unfortunate,
there's not a momentum.
This stands for Proton.
Proton.
Proton should farm the two protons and the new Proton and anti-proton created
from the vacuum created from nowhere.
This is what happens in a collider.
Particles and antiparticles are created in pairs using the incoming energy.
So it's the opposite of the atomic bomb.
Atomic bomb,
masses destroyed and energy is created in an accelerator.
Energy is converted into mass,
which is why two particles can go in and for particles at 10 or 14,000 can come
up.
So we wanted to look at the experiment where people were trying to make
antiprotons.
The theory says anti-proton mass at the same as the proton mass.
It's a very gentle symmetry of theories.
But do you want to make it,
and the question is,
what is the minimum energy of this incoming proton that'll make this reaction
possible?
This guy starts out at rest.
Yeah.
So how,
what energy are,
what momentum should the incoming
predict?
I'll have yes.
Uh,
uh,
and uh,
energy,
uh,
one or two.
Uh,
let's see.
So here are four par four protons and in the tempest collision,
what would they be doing in the end?
Uh,
no.
I'll just be like
sitting in a clump.
Yeah.
And what would be the energy of that plump?
Do you agree that's for them?
Yes.
Okay.
This guy brings energy,
emptied the collision,
big,
the static target.
So you will conclude the energy of this should be three m
okay.
By that we mean m c squared divided by one minus v squared over c square should
be three times Mc Square.
That's the energy.
You got that three.
This ambled make water.
Yep.
Why are um,
why don't we say that the [inaudible] are on the right that's coming in.
Is is m ones?
No,
no,
no.
The mass of these particles is always am I'm saying the energy of this guy is
three m
yes.
If this is three m and that guy brings a name just by sitting there and we need
for them to make for particles and we want the cheapest deal.
So nobody's doing anything
but this is wrong.
This is an underestimate for what you need.
You need more
think about why do we need more energy than this?
Yep.
[inaudible]
no,
right.
Let's say they don't annihilate their form and they are just,
they don't analyze it that fast.
So they can be produced.
Antiprotons can,
that's not the reason why
I want you to visualize the question we are asking.
Obviously,
if you send a super duper proton beam,
it can knock the hell out of this proton produce however many particles you
want.
You want the minimum energy.
And the picture we have is what's the minimum energy afford particles?
Whether it's for particles at rest,
that's the one that which the computer,
the energy.
But there's something wrong with that argument.
Yes sir.
Yeah.
So let me repeat what he said.
Law of conservation of momentum will not allow you to take a situation about a
proton comes in with momentum.
This guy is doing nothing and you cannot afford particles at rest because it had
momentum is zero.
Therefore,
the Ford guys who are produced must be drifting forward with some minimum
momentum so that that momentum equals incoming moment,
that means you got to pay the price to make them,
you got to pay the price to move them at a minimum momentum to balance the
incoming moment.
That's your tell you that the real energy of the incoming particle has gotta be
more than just a whatever I said three yet.
That'll be going to find out the real moment.
So the trick is again,
going to be the same.
So this the initial state is the final state,
but this final state has got some motion
cannot be addressed.
So what's the initial momentum?
Initial momentum for this guy is some energy.
He,
but this guy is a mass m and the momentum of business,
some number p and the moment of this guy is you.
That's the initial moment.
And that's gotta be equaled the final moment.
Very good.
Final momentum.
You can write down in detail by taking this for masters,
giving them some velocities.
But I'm not gonna do any of that.
Yes,
this em,
this particle has an energy m uh,
it's really Mc.
So I did this.
He oversee MC and zero.
This guy has got you oversee and some momentum.
PEA pod.
I've forgotten the sea.
Remember we agreed that we're not going worry about,
see in this problem.
So this is just an,
so this is the initial momentum that's going to be the final momentum.
That also means initial momentum is square,
is final momentum squared.
If two vectors at equal,
the squares are equal.
Now the final momentum square,
I could say we can evaluate not at the lab frame,
but in another frame called the center of mass frame.
And here is the center of mass frame.
Suppose you start moving to the right at some speed.
What do you think will happen?
Imagine in your head,
you move to the right,
this proton,
we'll start moving to the left.
This brought on will appear slower that let you
pick up your speed until they're coming in exactly opposite momentum.
That's the frame of reference you can imagine in that frame,
the collision looks rather different in that frame.
This guy and this guy at approaching each other with opposite velocities,
therefore equal and opposite momenta.
The total momentum is zero.
In that frame,
these two guys had allowed to go into four sitting ducks because the total
moment in Mizzou,
so that is the frame of reference called the center of mass frame.
In with incoming moment,
uh,
add up to zero.
So the final particles that are allowed to be at rest,
if they want to and the minimum energy coalition,
they will be produced at rest because that's the least expensive way.
So I found a frame in which this is possible.
That's not the lab frame,
that's a frame in which they're moving in opposite directions.
But what's the total momentum in this frame?
Total momentum at this frame B total is four m comma zero.
No,
no one stays.
The total momentum and that frame has to be the total moment and my frame,
but uh,
sorry to say p final,
no one says that be financial should be,
might be final,
but the square of that be final.
This is great or might be fine because it's great if any vector is the same for
all observers.
So what does be final square?
You guys should know by now this bad product of this vector of itself with the
square of this number.
Mine is zero.
There's nothing here
that fought.
I argue here that p initial square is equal to p final square that they
calculate in the center of mass frame and it gets 16 inch square.
Yes,
people,
right?
Why is the square of the Ford momentum the same in two frames of reference?
Anybody answered that?
Why is it [inaudible] are not equal,
but the squared is equal?
Why is that?
Because it's a dark product of a vector with itself.
And the whole idea of defining these squares so that they are the same for all
observers.
The whole idea of defining four vectors is that when you take the legs square
for four vector defined in this crazy way,
zero component squared minus the first component square.
That same for all people,
right?
That's the beauty.
That's why if you really look at the total momentum vector in the lab frame,
it looks like this and that's gotta be the final total momentum to these numbers
are not,
uh,
they are both non zero.
So Norman says the total momentum vector is the same in the center of mass
frame.
It looks like this,
but the square of the vector of must be this way or the vector for all people.
Well,
let me finish this and maybe we'll have a discussion.
So p initial squared is 16 m square.
So this is the pop most line.
Find the square of this vector is e plus m squared
minus B squared is 16 and square.
Yeah.
Uh,
so let's see where to write this.
Maybe I'll write it here.
That means east square plus m squared.
Let's do e n minus B squared is 16 named square.
Yeah.
What you must know that e squared minus B squared is the name square.
I'm saying e squared equal to p squared plus m square.
If you banish all those factors of c square.
So this ie squared minus B squared is an m square.
That's an already an m squared here.
So I get to m square.
Let's do e m equal to 16 m squared.
You canceled the two and make it 14 and squares and to divide by two m you find
e equals seven.
And
by the way,
this is posted on the web,
on the Internet,
so you guys can go.
You guys can read it whenever you like.
So don't worry about this last detail.
I've given you that every possible detail here,
if you didn't get every factor,
doesn't matter what I want you to understand this.
I have also given you the whole argument on how you go to this frame and that
frame.
The point is you get an answer that equals seven m you realize time to put back
the velocity of light and everybody knows even man and woman on the street that
this should be the only seven MC squares.
If it caddied factors of see throughout the calculation it would've been very
messy.
But here is where c squared,
what happened?
Turn out.
We're looking for an energy and you get a mask.
You put back the c square.
So what we are told is the incoming proton acid moves,
his energy goes from MC squared,
the bigger and bigger numbers because they're nominated and won over to B
squared.
C squared is vanishing.
Wait till the energy is seven times the rest energy.
You've been a seven times at Este energy,
that's when it's ready to hit the static proton and produce Proton antiproton
pairs from Norway.
So some of the m square is going to give a momentum to the fragments of the
collision and some ways to create and the way we found or the minimum energy
[inaudible] energy moment of calculation,
but the minimum energy configurations easily imagine in the center of mass
frame.
That's the whole point,
not in the lab,
free central mass from,
that's why accelerators nowadays is they're taking one particle,
make it move faster than passenger hitting a target.
The produce intersecting story drinks where the particles are going in opposite
directions and every time or they meet in the racetrack that allowed to collide.
What's the beauty of that?
Beauty of that is since they come to the opposite Momenta,
the final fragments don't have to move it all so you can make more and more
mass.
So don't put your energy all into one beam and a static target.
Put them into two oppositely moving beams.
Then all the energy is available for producing mass.
All right,
so I'll stop now.
I think this is a difficult chapter,
so you have to go and read and you have to talk to each other and try to do as
many problems as you can.